[Laughter]
this
is aciliate luxoty's magnus
it is about to die
of course depending on your time scale
we are all about to die
to the grand canyon or the sun things
that have existed for
millions or billions of years we are
each
weird little bubbles of peculiar
chemistry that form
and then pop form and then pop
but this ciliate and with our new
microscope you can really see those
cilia beating
is about to pop right before your eyes
it looks fine right now you can even see
inside at its last meal a trochleomonas
so we don't think it's starving to death
it seems to be
trucking along just fine luxoty's magnus
are microaerophilic organisms preferring
a low concentration of dissolved oxygen
in their environment but not too low so
maybe the concentration
on the slide was too high though we've
witnessed many others who have been just
fine
in our preparations so no
we can't tell you why this ciliate is
about to die
but we can tell you that right here
that's where james our master of
microscopes
first saw something strange the moment
the ciliate shifted direction
a little trail of cell membrane
and cytoplasm no reason
nothing grabbed it it didn't snag on
anything
but a little bit of what was once part
of the organism
was suddenly no longer a part of it
that cytoplasm is full of complicated
molecules that are what chemists would
call
far from equilibrium
equilibrium is the situation in which
chemicals no longer have a tendency to
react over time
in general a thing that you can say for
sure
is that all the stuff outside of living
cells
is either at chemical equilibrium or it
is headed there
whereas stuff inside cells is not
at equilibrium and it's not headed there
either how
are all these chemicals that if left
alone
would rapidly reach equilibrium managing
to not do that
life that is what life
is a bunch of chemicals that take in
energy in order to keep each other from
reaching
[Music]
equilibrium
quick break from our friend the way we
define
life in biology classes is wrong
it's not even really a definition it's a
set of qualifying
factors life has to take in energy life
has to reproduce it must respond to its
environment it must
consist of cells this is not a
definition it's an attempt
to draw a line to create a boundary
and that makes sense for things that are
actually amorphous and complicated
like social constructs but life
is not a construct of our opinions
but of reality life is a chemical system
that uses energy to keep itself from
reaching
chemical equilibrium
why did they do it oh well maybe let's
not go that deep
at least not today suffice it to say a
system
that did this developed on this planet
and now
billions of years later it is
still doing it
we have many things in common with this
ciliate
and not to belabor the point but one of
those things
is that we will die you've probably
noticed by now that this video
isn't about what life is it's about
what death is it's just that first
we had to define life life is chemicals
working together to take in energy to
keep themselves far from equilibrium
death is not the return to chemical
equilibrium
the process of decay can last decades
likewise many parts of my body will
return
to equilibrium over the course of my
life i'm shedding skin cells
right now and so are you the atoms and
molecules of my body are replaced with
new ones
over and over and over again
but i will only die once
likewise our ciliate has been shedding
cytoplasm and cell membrane for minutes
now
and that shed cytoplasm is dead no doubt
but the organism lives its chemistry
continues
for now death
is the moment when the system that
maintains the far
from equilibrium state ceases
existence and we can imagine that at
many scales
that can happen to individual bits of an
organism
as it is happening to the chemicals
spilling out of our luxodies right now
it can also happen to an individual cell
and an organism
and that happens all the time it is
happening right now
inside you it can also happen to an
organism
that's what we usually think of as death
with our focus
so often on the individual but we can
keep moving up the scale
and find yet other kinds of death when a
common genetic
system that was useful for keeping many
similar but individual organisms alive
ceases to exist that is an extinction
a kind of death and when the system
that has kept all life on earth far from
equilibrium for billions of years
that system that we all share of nucleic
and amino acids
when that ceases to exist that
will be something else a terrible kind
of death
that we do not even have a name for but
it will be a death
the largest death i suppose until heat
death
when everything in the universe has
found
equilibrium
[Music]
our ciliate is about out of time now
i don't know when we can call it when we
can pronounce the time of
death but this seems as good a time as
any
here we have death the system
that was using energy to keep itself
from reaching equilibrium has ceased to
exist
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen
world that surrounds us and thank you
as always and of course to all the
people
on the screen right now these are our
patreon patrons without whom
we could not make this show so if you
want to thank anybody
for enabling the existence
of content such as this on the internet
these are the people to thank if you
want to see more from our master of
microscopes james weiss you can check
out
jam and germs on instagram and if you
want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you